SPEAKER 1: Hello, I'm Jen
Person for the Developer Show.
This is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
The Google I/O 2018 schedule
just got a big update.
On it, you can find additional
sessions and code labs,
as well as new app
reviews, office hours,
and after hours events.
Head on over to the
post for links and info
on how to reserve your seat
or view the live stream.
For apps that target Android
P, TLS, or Transport Layer
Security, is the default. To
learn how to update your app,
including how to make clear
text connections when necessary,
take a look at the post.
Chrome 67 introduces several
new features and changes
to DevTools,
including the ability
to search across
all network headers
and CSS variable value
previews in the styles pane.
All the details with screen
shots are on the post.
Google and Netflix recently
announced Kayenta--
an open source, automated
canary analysis service
that allows teams to
reduce risk associated
with rolling out deployments
to production at high velocity.
Kayenta is integrated
with Spinnaker,
an open source, multi-cloud
continuous delivery platform.
All the details and links to
get started are on the post.
Google Cloud Endpoints is
a distributed API gateway
that you can use to develop,
deploy, protect, and monitor
APIs that you expose.
You can now configure Cloud
Endpoints to use a new managed
rollout strategy that
automatically uses the latest
service configuration without
having to redeploy or restart
it.
We recently added
version history
to Cloud Firestore
security rules.
For any Cloud
Firestore project, you
can now browse all previously
published versions of rules,
view the differences between
previous and current versions,
and edit the current version.
Details and screenshots
are on the post.
In 2016, we introduced
Firebase Cloud Messaging,
the next evolution in
Google Cloud Messaging.
It includes a host
of new features,
such as an intuitive
notifications interface
in the Firebase console,
better reporting,
and native integrations with
other Firebase products.
We're excited to devote more
time and attention to improving
FCM, which is why the GCM
server and client APIs have been
deprecated and will be removed
as soon as April 11, 2019,
meaning you will need to
upgrade to FCM within a year.
Of course, we recommend
you upgrade sooner
rather than later.
A step-by-step migration
guide is linked from the post.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Jen Person for
the Developer Show.
Thanks for watching.
I'll see you next week.
I feel like I hear Chariots of
Fire as I'm trying to do this.
I'm just on that Olympic
level of saying words.